-I want to ask about this,
because one of the things
that happened this week --
we all remember
famously July 27, 2016,
Donald Trump said if, "Russia,
if you're out there listening,
I'd love to see
Hillary Clinton's e-mails,"
basically invited them
to hack her server.
And it came up this week that
Robert Mueller basically said,
that day, they tried.
-Yes.
-So you confronted him
at the rally that day
about his comments.
-Yeah.
-What was it
that he said to you?
-It was the -- By the way,
it was the weirdest --
one of the weirdest moments in
what was a very weird campaign.
-Yeah, it's very --
Be careful with the --
-I know. I know.
-Yeah.
There were a lot of --
Now I'm thinking back,
and there were a lot.
-[ Chuckling ] Yeah, right.
-But this one was particularly
weird -- particularly weird.
We were in the middle
of one of his golf courses.
We're in a ballroom,
this very gaudy ballroom
with this patterned carpet.
-He has a -- All right.
-Yeah, I'm just gonna say it.
[ Laughter ]
It was -- It was a little
over -- over-decorated. Fine.
It was also really freezing
in there.
It's like he was trying
to freeze us
or send us to Siberia.
-[ Laughing ] Okay, got you.
-And he comes out.
It's the middle of the
Democratic National Convention.
Usually, presidents or
presidential candidates go dark
when they're not having
their convention,
but he wants the attention,
and there had been some rumors
about hacking --
the DNC had been hacked,
some e-mails came out,
it was very embarrassing
for the DNC,
and there was talk
about maybe it being Russia.
Nothing had been confirmed yet.
It was all
kind of bubbling out there.
Donald Trump comes out
and starts talking
about Russia all of a sudden
and how everybody thinks that
Russia is hacking.
"They're not hacking.
And, oh, by the way,
I want to see those e-mails."
And I remember sitting there
and thinking, "Uh, wait. What?
Did Donald Trump just ask
a foreign government
to hack
into Hillary Clinton's e-mails?
Did that just happen?"
That's even weird
by Donald Trump's standards.
-Sure.
-And -- And I remember thinking,
"I got to ask this guy
about it,"
and at this time,
he kind of hates me,
so he's not letting me
ask questions.
And the next couple questions
that came out
were about something else,
about the economy
or something just totally
not on the topic of Russia.
And I remember thinking, "Well,
maybe I'm the crazy person.
Maybe that's
a totally normal thing,
and that's just part
of politics, and I'm naive.
But eventually, I decide that,
no, it's a big question,
and I've got to get
his attention.
So I'm waving my arm
frantically,
and he's not calling on me.
And so I go back
to my tried and true strategy,
which is to flatter him
in order to get him
to pay attention to me.
And so I said, "Your poll
numbers are really great!"
And he turns and looks at me,
and he says, "Katy!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Katy, is that you?
Are you wearing a disguise?
Oh, no, that is you."
I said "Yes,
your poll numbers are great.
Let me ask you about Russia.
Does it not give you pause
to ask a foreign government
to hack into the election?"
He doesn't even let me finish
the sentence.
"No, it does not give me pause.
What should give you pause
is Hillary Clinton
and her missing e-mails."
And I said,
"Hold on. Hold on. Hold on."
You are asking
a foreign government to meddle."
And he's like, "You're
just trying to save her."
And I said, "No, no.
You're asking a foreign
government to meddle."
And he keeps steamrolling
over me,
and he, at the end of it, says,
"No, I would really like
to see those e-mails."
So that was a huge day.
This is an American
presidential candidate
asking for help
from a foreign government,
doing it very blatantly.
It was very weird.
But then,
the campaign continues on,
and he says a whole bunch
of other totally crazy things.
-Yeah.
-And the intelligence
community...
[ Light laughter ]
-Yeah, we just have to like --
Then we just throw stuff away.
We don't have room in there.
-Everything gets -- gets totally
buried by the next controversy,
which is what actually ended up
really helping him,
because you couldn't focus
on just one thing.
And a lot of folks asked,
"Well, why didn't you
press that harder?"
We had no indication whatsoever
from anybody
in the intelligence community.
Peter Strzok wasn't texting
any of us and saying,
"Hey, I got this information
on Donald Trump."
We had no idea.
The only hint we had to it
was that press release
that came out on October 7th,
which was also the day
that Donald Trump --
well, the tape came out
where Donald Trump was bragging
about grabbing women
by certain parts.
-Yeah. No memory.
No memory of that.
[ Laughter ]
-So that got buried.
That got buried.
And it was only a press release
that said
Russia wanted to meddle.
It had nothing to do with --
with Donald Trump's campaign.
Fast-forward to today,
and, oh, my God,
that date is so significant.
We had it come out in the --
in the indictment that Russia --
that Mueller put out on Friday,
saying July 27th,
the day Donald Trump said,
"Russia, if you're listening,"
that is the day that the
conspirators in the indictment,
these 12 Russians,
started for the first time --
and it says
it in the indictment --
for the first time --
tried to get into
Hillary Clinton's e-mails
and server.